-Our next guest is
a very funny comedian and acto
you know from "Fleabag."
He's the creator and star
of the excellent series
"Stath Lets Flats,"
which is available on HBO Max.
Let's take a look.
-And should we wait for Momm
to go in
or are we just
going to charge in?
-Me and her mum are separated.
-Oh, God.
♪♪ A-one, two, three-four, five
That was sort of a song for he
'cause she's quite young.
♪♪♪♪
Oh, and there's a chair!
...lettings!
This is a feature up here
that we tried to get rid of,
but in the end,
we decided we loved it.
And as you can see there's
an absolutely...shower.
-Please welcome to the sho
Jamie Demetriou.
How are you, Jamie?
-I feel quite nice.
Lovely to meet you, Seth.
-It's lovely to meet you
as well.
We have a friend in common
Ike Barinholtz.
And he was the first perso
who told me about your show.
And the title is such --
I've gotten used to it.
I love it now.
When I first heard it, it's very
frustrating because I --
I literally had to have hi
spell it for me.
because "Stath Lets Flats"
is such a weird earful.
Do you love the title
or do you regret it?
-You know, there are times -
[ Laughs ]
There are times in your life
where you take your eye
off the ball, and naming my show
something that I find hard
to say definitely
feels like one of them.
I mean, I do remember pitching
the name "Stath Lets Flats,"
and the room sort of
going quiet
and us going, "Okay, so we
definitely won't call it that.
[ Laughter ]
And then sort of hard cut to
it coming out on TV,
and we're all like,
"Oh, how did we --
how did we let that happen
No one was into
'Apartment Dudes'?
None? Alright. Cool."
-Well, so your character -
it does -- it is very clea
that it spells out
what's happening in the show
Your character's name is Stath
and you let or rent
flats, apartments.
So it all makes sense.
I'm wondering. You did not hav
any experience letting flats
Did you have to shadow peopl
who did this for a living?
-Oh, not so much shadow.
I just booked some -- I booked
some viewings of some properties
that I didn't necessarily
want to rent or buy.
And it is the gift
that keeps on giving.
It's like they knew I was coming
and were like,
"We need to give him
some inspiration for his sho
'cause -- let's do the dumbest
thing we can possibly do
because it's a waste of time
for him if we don't."
So, yeah, I had all kinds of -
I mean, I went into one plac
and the -- it was freezing cold,
and I said to the guy,
"Is the heating on?"
He went,
"Yeah, it is, actually."
And I was like,
"Oh, that's not great, is it
Because it's so cold. And is
the window, like, rattling
It looks like it's got
some cracks in it."
And he said, "Right.
I know what you're thinking.
And you're thinking
that it's cold and that the heat
is not working
and that the window is bad
And I understand
why you think that.
But trust me, none of thos
things are the case."
[ Laughter ]
"None of those things are true."
No reason, just that.
So there was born a TV show.
-Have you received any feedbac
post it airing
from those
in the apartment arts?
Do people like the show
who do this for a living?
-"The apartment arts"
is being used.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I think because,
you know, by the very nature o
those characters, they don't
have a huge amount of
introspection going on.
So when they watch the show,
they immediately deflect.
Like, the amount of times I've
been into a Realtor's office
or a letting agent's offic
as what we call it
and they've been like,
"Oh, my God.
You are -- Your character
is exactly like this guy
who works in our office,
who's an idiot."
And more often than not
they're pointing at a guy
who seems really sweet and i
just trying to eat a sandwic
in the corner of the room,
and I'm like,
"I think I might be
more like you."
[ Laughter ]
-I did not realize this,
but your sister in the show,
who is fantastic, is your sister
in real life, Natasia,
who I also knew from
"What We Do in Shadows."
I mean, it must be outstanding
getting to work with each othe
for no reason less than
how talented she is.
-Right. I think that's it.
The privilege is,
first and foremost,
working with her as an actor
You know, I probably would hav
wanted her to be in it anywa
because she's my sister,
but the true luck of it al
is that whether or not
she was my sister,
I'd need her for that role
because she's just unreal.
And we have, like, a --
you know, it's so much easie
when you have a sure hand.
I mean, most of the cast
are my pals or people
I came up with
and we share a sensibility
But with Tash, it literall
comes down to, like,
if she's ever being given
direction, you have, like,
a sure hand of experience,
like, history together.
So I can be like, "You kno
when our cousin in Cyprus
dropped us off
in the middle of the highway
because he said he needed to g
and buy a fish,
and then he asked us if we liked
fish, and we said no,
and he drove off?
Can you pull the expression that
he pulled as he drove off?
Okay?" And she's like,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah. Got you."
[ Laughter ]
-I also -- I think this is -
what I'm saying is a complimen
because I never would
make the connection with
how you looked in "Fleabag
with how you look in real life
But you played Bus Rodent in
the first episode of "Fleabag"
with maybe the most distressin
fake teeth I've ever seen.
How was that experience?
Because obviously that is --
that's one for the history
books, that show.
-I mean, yeah. Right.
I mean, I learned so much
from Phoebe on set.
Her manner and her kind of -
you know,
it's a bar to be reached, so i
was a really amazing experience.
And I'm just so happy it too
off in the way that it did
You know, the teeth thing
is interesting.
I went into a lot of casting
calls after it came out,
and there would always be
a sort of 15-second silence,
where you could tell the casting
director wasn't listening to
what I was saying
because they were waiting for me
to open my mouth wide enough
to look inside.
[ Laughter ]
They'd be like,
"Hey, how are you?
You're from..."
[ Laughter ]
"They're not real. Yeah.
Okay. So let's --"
I'm like, "If I -- you know,
if that guy did exist, you know,
he's going to have a hard time
bagging some roles."
-He got the one, and that wa
gonna be the last one.
-Right. He's like, "Oh, my God
Look at this script."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm so excited to hear
that you're working on scripts
for a third season now.
It's such a great show.
So great to meet you. Thanks
so much for being here, Jamie.
-Man, pleasure.
Thanks so much for having me